foreign
shielding his sister a monument from
2014 when Ukrainian shells hit donask in
the last year of fighting here at least
35 more children have been killed and in
the last nine years of conflict Russian
officials estimate thousands have died
in russian-controlled territories
the dangers and her grandchildren have
stayed in donyesque one of her two
daughters is being treated in hospital
after a shell exploded near her
the other had to find work after her
husband fled to Ukraine but no matter
how hard life here gets she isn't ready
to leave
no categorically not I grew up on this
land I buried my parents here I'm
bringing up my grandchildren here I grew
up on this land why should I leave it
at least one woman was killed in the
latest Ukrainian artillery strikes on
homes in donyesque
scenes like this have become routine
many have lived under constant fear
since russian-backed separatists rose up
against Ukraine
Human Rights Watch has accused Russia of
carrying out indiscriminate attacks
against civilians and Ukrainian forces
of violating laws of war
it's gathered testimony about alleged
mistreatment and summary executions of
prisoners of War as well as the use of
banned weapons
Human Rights Watch says Ukrainian forces
used urugan cluster munition rockets in
an attack on hosarevka in Harkey region
from May to early September Ukrainian
forces repeatedly attacked the city of
isium and surrounding areas while they
were under Russian control with cluster
munitions
since Russia annexed these regions last
year many here now have Russian
passports but that doesn't take away the
dread of the next incoming missile
we are all at Great risk I get up to go
to work and I don't know whether or not
a missile will hit us when I'm on the
bus I don't know if Rockets will strike
we can stay indoors forever I need to
leave my house we just pray and go
outside
it is dangerous but I have to go
Outdoors we have to eat something we
must buy Essentials
this man says he was building a snowman
with his daughter when a shell exploded
next to them they survived with minor
injuries
so now parents don't meet in Parks
anymore most swings and slides are empty
because of the contested status even Aid
workers such as the Red Cross do not
enter these territories it's day one of
year two since the war in Ukraine for
people living in parts of eastern
Ukraine the war has continued for nearly
a decade Moscow